running the business is hard I get
people write in to me all the time
telling me how hard it is to run their
business you know you don't have the
money you don't have resources you don't
have contacts people give excuses they
say oh I'm too old I'm too young I'm not
from North America I didn't grow up in
an entrepreneurial family I don't have
money
you know I'm disabled I'm a woman you
know people come up with all these
excuses none of that stuff matters yeah
it's hard running the business it's
really really hard I don't know why you
think it's easy this is gonna be the
hardest thing you ever do in your life
it's hard there's gonna be a lot of crap
thrown at you and this is where you find
out about yourself this is where you
learn are you the kind of person who
shrinks when you come up up against
something difficult or do you rise to
the challenge I got an email from one of
my newsletter readers Sam who wrote in
to say hi Evan I'm 23 years old I don't
have a lot of money you know I was
employed at a company and I had an
accident and I hurt my arm I want to
make a difference though setting up my
own macquarie in business how can I
overcome the challenges that I have to
achieve that dream okay so you're young
you don't have any money and you hurt
your arm
I don't know how badly you hurt your arm
I'm I'm really you know sorry to hear
that if I had a way to turn that thing
around I would but it doesn't matter you
know that might sound heartless
that might sound rude but the fact that
you're young the fact that you don't
have money the fact that you hurt your
arm does not impact you being a success
because you can find people you can you
look at famous entrepreneurs you look at
the people who made it big you look at
their background they overcame crazy
odds the people will get it handed to
them they never take off you look at who
the most successful people are you look
at where they came from it's usually
nothing nobody all the problems your
time no money immigrant woman yeah
different country you know all the
things you think are problems these are
tests for you the people who get it
handed to them who have all the
advantages you look what they do with
their life it's usually nothing great
the second generation third generation
entrepreneurs where they are handed a
business from their parents handed
everything to them on a silver platter
that's when the company starts to tank
its the founder the person who came from
nothing who overcame all those problems
those are the people who take off and
they had all the same problems that you
have so this is just an excuse this is a
story you tell yourself and you have two
options okay this is why it's important
because a lot of people come up against
this point this is a defining moment for
you okay you hurt your arm and I'm sorry
for that
you have two choices you either live the
rest of your life saying I couldn't do
it because my arm I couldn't do it cuz
of my arm I wish I could have built this
aquarium but I couldn't because of my
arm
or you keep going and you say I built my
dream who cares about my arm you don't
need your your right arm or your left
are in the building aquarium you don't
need any arms you don't need any legs
all you need is this as long as your
heart is still beating you still have a
chance that's the difference
you want to turn this thing into a
success get started what are you doing
right now to build your aquarium what
are you doing right now to build your
dream every day take a take a step
forward make progress that's how you
start accomplishing your dream and
you're gonna come you know what I got
news shoot that arm thing that money
thing you're gonna have a hundred more
challenges just like it a hundred more
challenges just like it this is your
first test let's see how you do you want
to be successful you have to continue to
believe I'd love to hear what you guys
have to think that those are you
watching leave a comment below telling
about the problems that you've had to
overcome this is a famous entrepreneur
who you look up to and their challenges
share below because this helps motivate
people who are also going through
struggles so please share it let me know
what you think leave a thumbs up if you
liked this video and click on my face to
subscribe to the channel thank you so
much I'll see you soon